the other thing was that it was a very
frightening situation one evening at
seven o'clock we had a gathering outside
of about 40 youths that in itself is bad
enough but some of the girls were
terrible and there was a confrontation
between upstairs and down in the car
park then we'd another car pull up chap
come out wonder what ever he was going
to get out of his boot but he got out
boxing gloves and was you know itching
for a fight and that was you didn't know
where to go you just wanted to keep in
your house you couldn't walk through the
car park it was a good job we didn't
have to go anywhere and that was very
frightening and you know the lack of
sleep one night I think it stopped at
about half past two and then at six
o'clock quarter to six in the morning we
had all the cars their cars out in the
car park peeping their horns so you
didn't get any sleep can you just
explain to us what close your order is
yeah closure is where we the police and
the council apply to the magistrates for
them to legally close the premises down
IE evict any tenants from that address
for period up to three months thank you
and in your experience we understand
you've got a lot of experience of
working with closure orders could you
tell us a little bit about the types of
behavior that you're aware of that have
happened have led to closure orders yeah
we offer I have experienced four
incidents where we've had to apply for a
closure closure order and the the
behavior has been all sorts from
drunkenness to fight in litter noise
complaints just all sorts of antisocial
behavior and can you tell us about what
happens once the closure order is
granted and how that affects the quality
of life for the residents well once a
closure
order has been granted the occupant the
tenants are immediately evicted they
have a very short space of time I hours
to gather their personal possessions
together and they are actually then they
are removed from the premises and the
premises boarded up if if necessary teen
housing got involved and the police got
involved in the district council and a
closure order was actually obtained on
the property now that was what resulted
the resultant action can you tell us
what life is like now for the residents
now we're back to how we were before
before the young lady came here to live
everybody's speaking to one another now
we can keep the place clean and the
outside and life is getting back to
where we can enjoy life you know that is
the most simplest way to put it what
advice would you give to anybody else
you found themselves in a similar
situation to you they shouldn't get
upset to the extent where they want to
hide themselves they must be aware that
if nothing is done then it's just going
to get worse so really when if they are
actually timid and they don't want to
speak to the person well they sweet teen
housing or they speak to the police
because the help you get especially from
the police as well that they will guide
you through things teen housing with us
they had a meeting with with all the
residents they explained to us exactly
what they were going to do how things
were going to take place so you have
helped and you must not think that
you've got to lock yourself inside the
house and think well I gotta stop here
you have to speak about it go to the
place team Housing Council and they will
help you out and they will deal with the
met
so after the closure world has been
granted what sort of difference in
quality of life have you witnessed from
the residents oh it's been immense I've
had residents coming up to me thanking
me they've been writing letters of
appreciation they've even been and
they've carried out radio interviews
with local radio stations because just
to have that peace and quiet and their
their life back again that that sense of
normality there they're really really
pleased and for me as a police officer
and as the neighborhood beat manager
it's exactly that what I'm after is is
that the residents can can all get on
together and have a real real good
quality of life so it's it really is a
win-win situation thank you very much